hey what's up this is john with the dr
john daloni show today we are talking
about infertility
and a lot of immaturity stay with us
hey good folks i am john and this is the
dr john deloney show
it's a collar driven show we're talking
to real people about real
challenges what kind of challenges
talking about relationships relational
iq
your mental health parenting
dating right being a good friend or that
annoying guy at your
office that will not shut up about
keto and how great his life is now that
he's on keto
dude i don't eat grains and sugars
either we get it man
and while i'm here while i'm here dude
vegans
congratulations we get it you are
morally superior to the rest of us you
are incredible
and i i i do mental health for a living
and i've tried to figure out how carrots
and lettuce elevate the human spirit i
don't get it but
good for you but how about this let's
just turn it back a couple of notches
just
let's dial it back we're all on the same
team here and we're all moving forward
anyway in a world of chaos a world where
people just need truth
and they want a second opinion i'm here
to walk with you so give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
keto fanatics vegans everybody's welcome
everybody belongs on the dr john delony
show
i hope you're doing well hope
everybody's doing okay last night at my
house
man a wackadoo tornado storm
came through and knocked all the power
out the internet out the satellite
everything was out
my wife just texted and said she's on
the
phone on hold with the internet company
she said her estimated wait time is
478 minutes and she said and i'm not
even kidding
so that's the kind of morning we woke up
to but we're gonna make it good we're
gonna have fun
and we're gonna go straight to the
phones here we got justin in
las vegas nevada justin how are you this
morning man
i'm doing well about you dr d doing all
right brother how can i help man
uh some little back story i guess uh so
i met once and i haven't even known for
about 10 years
hey uh your call's muffled a little bit
talk directly into the phone there
can you hear me now uh perfect all right
cool
uh so yeah a little back story uh my
youth and i we've been married for about
10 years uh about five or so years ago
we found out that we can't have uh
children naturally
okay um so we're hoping to hopefully be
back soon
uh but my my question comes from my wife
has a younger sister she's about 10
years younger
and then he got married about a year ago
and just found out
that they were pregnant it's completely
unplanned but they're happy
we're happy for them um we
well we my wife and i can't help but
tell a little jealousy
sure um it's a it's a large family so
we we try to get together at least once
a week and and
since we found about this about this
pregnancy a month ago it's a huge topic
of conversation at every family
gathering
um and so like like i said we're kind of
some kind of jealous and
we're not sure how to handle it i'm more
of a
confrontal person i just want to tell
them to stop talking and have a
psychopath
um my wife is the exact opposite uh
there's been nights when we get home
and then she'll start crying and kind of
crying to me
saying it's not fair and but again we're
happy
so again we're not sure what to do um is
this a conversation
with your family or something we need to
figure out
to deal with on our own i don't like
that you're making this a binary choice
man
and so i'm going to speak from
experience here my wife and i
experienced
seasons where we were trying to have
kids and it didn't work out for us
we ended up being fortunate enough to
have two biological kids down the road
but
there was big chunks of seasons
throughout that time
and so man i want to affirm you i've
been there the pain is
real the pain is super real and it is
frustrating
and annoying and all of those things to
hear other people
talk about it um i remember having
conversations with my friends my wife
um when people would say oh no we're
pregnant again
or you know the somebody
at church or somebody at work would be
talking about their 18 year old they
found out they're having a child and
there was this sense that they didn't
want the kid and it was unplanned and
what are we gonna do
and we're over here thinking golly it
would be so great
this is all that we thought we wanted at
the time
um so that's real and good
what i'm concerned about is that you're
making it an either or that you either
have to shut down the conversation
and effectively own um
taking joy off the table for your family
for
um whoever else is pregnant in your in
in your family
and your parents your in-laws and
or it's got to be the other thing and i
just don't i don't think it it has to be
either or
you said you were confrontational why
would you want to
stop that conversation when your
family's talking about
um we're so excited we're gonna have a
new baby in the in the family why would
you feel the need to
tell them to stop talking about it just
because you're uncomfortable
yeah i mean i like i said i'm happy for
them i'm
totally stoked and happy for this this
child in this new real time
but yeah i once we get once we start
bringing it up
oh as a good topic in the land for
minutes and
longer a party starts getting annoyed
and wants to change the conversation
why do you get annoyed i
like i said it's more jealousy um
because
we want this um
and it's kind of more of a jealousy kind
of thing is like
yeah so here's the deal man
i don't want to be a jerk but i'm going
to be direct with you i promise
everybody i'll tell the truth
um jealousy is normal and jealousy's
fine
it's when you say i'm going to take my
ball and go home that's when you act
like a fifth grader
um it's when i'm uncomfortable and since
i'm uncomfortable then y'all all have to
stop being comfortable
so that we can all have this neutral
playing field right
um and man i i want to encourage you
strongly dude don't do that don't take
other people's joy
that doesn't lessen your hurt right um
but there is a moment where
you can celebrate with them you can be
joyful with them
there's also seasons where you know what
i can't have that conversation today
dude so i'm not going to go
i'm going to remove myself from that
situation but i'm not going to take
their joy from them does that make sense
so yeah you all get together all the
time
maybe you and your wife skip a couple of
those
and y'all go on a date night together
and maybe the dynamic has shifted for a
little while until you guys heal or
until you guys are able to adopt and
bring your own home
your own kid home but i just man
taking other people's joy is um because
you're jealous or because you're annoyed
by the conversation or you're frustrated
that they have something that you don't
have
um man that's immaturity at its deepest
and
and most rooted right and that doesn't
minimize your pain
um but all you can control is your
thoughts and actions right
and you choose to act mature and choose
to act um
in other people's best interests right
right
so this is a more personal question
who's
who's biologically challenged is it you
or your wife
uh she is she is okay
and so what i want to also encourage you
to do is that's an extra
deep um painful burden for her to carry
um and as a guy i'm gonna be honest and
vulnerable dude i
missed it by a hundred miles um
i did not understand the depth of my
body's failing me
that my body doesn't work right i'm
broken
i i'm a woman and i'm put here on earth
for one thing and i can't do the one
thing
man i missed that so deeply
and i want you to at the same time
you're celebrating
your other family members as they have
one kid and two kid and seven kids and
all that stuff
i want you to not minimize your wife's
pain because this is existential this is
spiritual and this is deep deep deep in
her heart
and so that may mean that y'all go talk
to somebody
that may mean that you spend some extra
time not trying to solve her problems
but being with her and
listening to her um and encouraging her
to talk that means you all may
keep a like a couple's journal together
on your journey towards adoption
and give her an opportunity to voice
some of that pain that she's feeling
that it's not something that um justin
it's not something that you and i can
understand
but it's something that we have to be
aware and be really acutely attuned to
okay okay is she speaking with anybody
she has someone that she talks to does
she have
women in her life that that she trusts
that she can be vulnerable with
uh she's in the past she doesn't know
all right she used to speak to a
therapist in the past
when we first found out but right now
she
has her sister she has her mom
she's really close with her family she
has a couple friends
that you're really close to and this
conversation that we've had
good deal well man it sounds like you're
you're on it with her and i'm glad that
she's got resources and support
um the greatest thing a partner can do
especially a knuckleheaded guy like me
knucklehead a guy like you justin and
i'm just lumping you in with all of us
a great thing you can do is to be make
intentional time
where you will hold her hands you will
look her in the eye
and you say i want to hear how you're
really doing today
and she'll may soft play it because she
wants to protect your feelings and your
heart too
and when she says i'm good i'm just
upset i just don't want to hear the
stories anymore you say great things
but really how are you doing today and
then when she tells you
she may not she may unload on you she
may
um cry from a place that you didn't know
she had inside of her
i don't want you to try to solve it i
don't want you to give her more
information i want you to hold her hands
i want you to look in the eye and say
that sucks but i love you
and thank you for sharing and justin
that's it
every guy across the country the women
in our lives need
less information less of us trying to
solve their hurt and pain
and more of us being with them just
hearing and acknowledging looking them
in the eye and saying this sucks it's
not
fair it's wrong it hurts i'm jealous i'm
pissed off i'm frustrated
and i hear you and thank you for sharing
that and just the presence of being
with somebody is so powerful important
man but justin thank you so much for
that call brother
and yeah to everybody there is a
difference between
your pain and taking somebody else's joy
off the table and wherever
possible pain is not some zero there's
not just a certain amount of pain
comparing pain doesn't do any good pain
pain is pain hurt is hurt it is what it
is
but joy is the same way there's not some
zero on joy
and justin and his wife are gonna have
to reframe what their picture was gonna
be
they're gonna adopt they're gonna have a
beautiful adoptive family it's going to
be incredible they're going to
love them deeply they're going to be
great parents but it's going to be a
different picture
and that's all right that's a different
picture but it's not a broken picture
and it's not a bad picture it's not a
second rape picture just a different one
right so good for you justin we'll be
thinking about your brother
after you adopt after you get that first
baby and you come home justin i want you
to call me back because we're going to
celebrate with you here
on the the show all right let's go to
katie
in dickinson north dakota katie good
morning how are you
i'm doing well how are you john good
good good how can i help you this
morning
well i was calling because a couple
years ago ryan and i
my husband and i we went through a
really tough time
we moved out to this rural place in
north dakota and i just
started living this kind of single life
even though we were still married and
um what does that mean what does that
mean
uh just like so he was working nights
and i had a bunch of time to myself i
was working remotely i didn't get a lot
of adult interaction so
i picked up like an extra job and i was
after my job i would go out every night
and i would
stay out late and i was
you know making friends with guys and
even though it was platonic like i
i didn't understand how uh
i don't know i guess irresponsible or
not okay that was
um and so he there's a lot of trust
issues
uh just because then he was kind of
trying to forbid me to hang out with
these guys and i didn't really get
get it and how important it was to him
and so i
i just didn't stop and we would you know
go play basketball and then go hit the
bars and go
play volleyball and then you know have
something to drink and
it was just uh did you ever cheat on him
yeah it was
i did not so that's one thing is that
while
no infidelity occurred you know he was
still
as broken as if it did occur and
after this time we had a certain amount
of time i can't remember if it was six
months
you know we we finally got to this
breaking point where
i think it hit me and we went to a
counselor and we saw a good priest
and over time i would say about two
years ago now we
we got to a point where we were whole
again and
while while it still hurts for him so
this is why i'm calling because
you know we you know couples fight so a
couple days ago
a fight happened and he brought up you
know stuff that happened
you know six months ago eight months ago
two years ago
and he brings it into current fights and
while i want to be understanding of his
wounds and i
totally know i i heard him and he's got
he still has these trust issues not only
with me but his past relationships
you know how can i be understanding and
listen
and be a good wife and
and um and listen you know and not but
not
dwell on these past issues i mean i
don't want to live in the past because i
really didn't like how ugly of a person
i was
but i have to know that that's still so
fresh in his mind and those
probably trust issues are going to come
up for a while yet and how how do we
work around this or how how can i
be be more understanding of this while
not
oh yeah just dwelling on that person i
was i think
number one you've got to forgive
yourself
and if your husband threw time with a
counselor through time with
just time separate right for a couple of
years since then
if your husband's forgiven you if he sat
with your pastor your priest and
he said he forgives you you've got to
forgive you number one
number two fights and painful moments
man they dredge up old stuff and
things come firing out of us sometimes
um
and you've got to give him some grace
too but at the same time he's
if he said he forgives you and he said
he's ready to work on the mirror just
two years ago and y'all are whole and
you're moving forward
then you're whole and you're moving
forward and so at some point he's got to
stop weaponizing the past also
right now i'm telling you that to tell
you this you cannot
in a heated moment bring that up that's
not helpful
that's not supportive um
afterwards right you all go to breakfast
you go have lunch
and you talk about the fight and you say
hey i didn't like what i said
um i got frustrated
but i need you to not weaponize the past
again
and you said you forgive me you said we
put that stuff down i'm living this new
life i've recommitted to our
relationship we're two years away from
that stuff now
let's continue to move forward and at
some point both of you have to put those
bricks down and stop
using them to burden yourselves or stop
using them as weapons or you just need
to go your separate ways
right and i'm not a fan of that at all
it sounds like you've reconciled it and
y'all are back in the same place but
picking up old bricks to throw them at
each other it does nobody any good
it just leaves bloody broken messes
so if he even if he has forgiven me like
obviously this hurt
is still you know itself maybe
more fresh in his mind than than we
would like it to be is that something
where he needs to go see a counselor by
himself was it
would it be more beneficial for us to
see a counselor together you know we've
had some sessions we've obviously been
through marriage counseling
you know for quite a while but you know
we took we haven't been to one for
probably a year now or is that just
something he needs to work
maybe i should give him the option to
work through himself or if he wants me
by his side
yeah i think asking him i think that's
being a supportive partner asking
him to um what he needs
what he would like right his role in
this deal yeah i think it's
i think you're a year out after
something that was tough for both of you
um whatever it works it you all
experience it as tough so
a year out yeah go get a tune-up go
check in
let him know you didn't like the way
that fight ended you didn't like stuff
coming up from a couple of years ago
that you thought you were both past
you sound like you need help forgiving
you and you're still like to go back
to the backyard and pick up old bricks
and carry them around to the front yard
every once in a while
we all do that when i get sleepy and i
haven't been eating
well and i'm having moments of shame and
self-doubt
i'll think of things i said when i was
14 that i wish i could have
back and i'm an old man now and and i
i don't know where those things come
from but they pop up and i've got to be
really diligent about controlling my
thoughts and my behaviors and not giving
them head space to
dwell and to take root again but your
husband's got to go do some work for
himself
you mentioned he's got past
relationships where he's got challenges
he obviously ran into some trust issues
with you
he didn't like the way you were handling
yourself which and let's be honest i
don't blame him
right if he's working nights he's
feeling like he's supporting you he's
supporting this family he's trying to
grow this new house
and you basically started dating again
you didn't you didn't cheat on him you
didn't
um uh do anything that violated the
letter of the law there but for whatever
reason
he was uncomfortable with you having a
bunch of guy friends and going to bars
and going to play
and going to hanging out and going to
movies which again i don't blame him
but at the same time sound like you talk
to you y'all work it out you forgave
each other you went and got counseling
and now you've moved on to this new life
so i don't want to belabor the point but
at some point he's going to have to go
through the work to get whole too
because he's still hanging onto stuff
and this is a broader conversation for
everybody
this idea that once you forgive
something and you look somebody in the
eye
and you say i am done i forgive you
i am giving you pardon
or you've made um you've paid your
penance
we're back together here to pick that
back up and hit somebody with that
is just violence it just doesn't make
any sense it doesn't help you
it doesn't heal them i do understand
saying things when you get frustrated
when you get sad and you get upset
when your patience and your wisdom and
your exhaustion
thins out your decision-making ability
things pop
out i get that um but don't bring up
stuff from the past just to abuse folks
with don't do that
don't do that and if you feel yourself
doing it if you feel yourself that
becoming your default setting
you know this is the third night this
week the dishes are out
just like that time three years ago
don't do that don't do that
because that becomes your issue not
theirs and by the way
katie it wouldn't surprise me if there's
behaviors going on in your heart
if there's a distance a small gap a
wedge between the two of you that may be
establishing itself again
that he feels that he's beginning to
feel this tension this pull apart
and maybe i'm making that up i'd love to
talk to him so at some point but
man leaning back into connection with
him taking him out this weekend and
saying i did not like the fight we had
i'm sorry for the role i played but wow
when you brought up that stuff from two
years ago that hurt
where did that come from why is that
still there
i think that'd be wise i think that'd be
wise you re reconnecting katie
all right let's go to take uh one more
call let's talk to matt in louisville
matt hey why before we get going is it
louisville or louisville
it's louisville louisville i'm from
texas no when somebody's not from the
area because they say louisville or
louisville
i'm from texas in tennessee i'm going
with louisville man
all right matt from wolves
go ahead brother yeah um so
i'm calling in because uh my wife and i
we've been married almost 10 years in
this october
this coming up october um
this has come up before where she said
that i've just
been a very selfish person um
a lot of times like she'll come and tell
me that i've made her upset about
something
and my go-to emotion seems to just be
anger like um i just get mad at her
for telling me that i messed up with
something
and that i didn't fix something the
right way
and like i guess i kind of get scared
like when she brings that to me because
i feel like i'm supposed to fix her
problems
even if it's not a problem between us
it's just an emotion that she's had
with someone else and she's coming to me
because i'm her husband i'm supposed to
be there to listen to her
and i just i don't know why but my go-to
emotion is anchored
you just jumped issues on me so she you
you made it sound like one thing but
it's actually two
so she comes to you with challenges
about you first
and you respond with anger and then
separately so as a period at the end of
that sentence then separately she comes
and talks about other feelings she's
having
about other issues she's having other
people and that makes you angry and
frustrated too because you know how to
solve those
right yeah okay so let's deal with the
first one when she comes to you and says
she's got problems with you or she
doesn't like the way you've done
something
is she right 90
of the time yeah so why do you get angry
i guess because i try to be i'm a
perfectionist i try to make everything
perfect
and when something doesn't go the way i
thought it should go
it angers me and if i'm
if i'm doing something and i thought i
did it correctly and it was great
but it upset her and then she comes and
tells me about it
that i think that's where the anger
comes from and i thought well in my head
it was perfect
and it was great but are you angry at
her or angry at you
i think ultimately i'm angry at myself
but i take it out on her
[Music]
and maybe i am angry at her too for a
little bit because she pointed it out
but i know that's how i grow and i
make improvements to myself when people
point those
criticisms out to me yeah so
dude here's the thing um dr chip dodd i
love the way he presents anger
uh he helped me reimagine anger all
anger
is is a cue that you care about
something
it's a good thing it is a
directional arrow towards something that
you're passionate about that you love or
that you care about
that's what anger is right okay acting
immature
and acting like a six-year-old and
stomping your feet and yelling or
lashing out to somebody at somebody
who's trying to help
you is
um like i said that's acting like a baby
acting like a child
and so feeling angry having that well up
inside of you i tried my best and it
wasn't good enough or i tried my best
and i just did the wrong thing
man that's natural feeling that's good
treating your wife
with disrespect treating her without
dignity just because she's trying to
lean into you man that's not cool at the
end of the day you're letting your
feelings and your emotions
drive your car instead of your thoughts
and your actions
okay and so the default setting you've
got to adjust to brother
is think about a car the front two tires
those are your thoughts your thinking
and your actions and so when she comes
in and says hey man
you did the dishes last night you put
them on the wrong spot we've talked
about this can you please put them in
the right spot
and that thought pops in your head oh
yeah well you
that's when you have a moment to stop
stop that thought and say nope
and then you can replace that thought
with you're right we've talked about
this and i was trying to do something
nice
um and i didn't do it right and i'm
going to fix that and then your actions
are you can stand up and go fix it
or you can stand up and look her now and
say thank you for telling me that i was
an idiot
and let that be that but instead you're
letting the back two tires of your car
which is your physiology like the way
your body feels you get your heart gets
racing and your chest gets tight and you
flex your muscles and you're like what's
up
and your emotions right they rage you
just get angry angry
right right and so you have got to
practice
moving your letting the front two wheels
of your car drive brother
and then the other side of this man when
she comes to you with
hey this happened today this is a
feeling i had this is a frustration
why do you get angry about that when
she's trying to connect with you that
way
i don't know that's that's a really good
question and that's kind of like what
i'm trying to figure out is why
that upsets me i guess that's where like
my selfishness comes in
to where i'm just like well that
happened to you that didn't happen to me
but that sounds like really bad when i
hear it i've never actually
said that out loud and that doesn't make
me feel good
so i'm i'm laughing i'm laughing at you
not with you okay like
why would somebody that you're married
to for a decade of your life she's
basically another arm and leg for you
right
why does her thoughts and feelings annoy
you
i don't know it's a good question where
is that selfishness rooted in man
i guess maybe that i feel like
i don't i don't really know i don't want
to say this
um because she has i mean there's a
couple issues that we're
trying to deal with we actually just
started marriage counseling monday
night right and so we're kind of working
through that
but um i know when
something hasn't happened that
i need in our marriage it
makes those times when she comes to me
with her feelings
and i'm i'm kind of like acting selfish
so i'm like well
you didn't give me what i need so i'm
not going to give you what you need
so are you talking about sex she doesn't
perform like you wanted to or with the
regularity you want so you're going to
show her
right and where does that where does
that behavior usually start
i'll just cut to the chase it starts on
a playground
right you didn't pick me for your team
so i'm not gonna pick you for my team
again we are
back to back to my
brother matt in louisville acting like a
four-year-old
the beauty is i will say this you've
done a very
um admirable adult thing and you have
decided you're gonna go work on this
now she may be dragging you but the deal
is you're going here's what i want you
to promise me
and the entire world listening to this
podcast you got it
yep when you go to your next counseling
session
i want you to tell them i talked to some
yahoo on the radio some quack on a
podcast
and i said some things out loud that
made me realize i'm selfish
and i'm immature and i want to fix that
and my promise to you is there are ways
to fix that
you and your wife are in a wonky
dance right now where you have shut off
all environmental signals for intimacy
and for connection because she's coming
to you with her feelings she's coming to
you with her heart
and you are getting frustrated and
annoyed by that because she's
interrupting your game
or you're checking out golf stuff on a
website or whatever weird stuff you do
in louisville
and you're frustrated and so she has
no environmental um
signal saying that you want to be
connected you want to be intimate and
then you circle around and be like hey
i'm not getting enough sex
and so i'm going to show you and there's
nothing sexual about what's going on in
your house right now because
you're annoyed by her you're annoyed
when she shares her heart you're annoyed
when
she doesn't do exactly what you want and
it's just making this figure eight of
frustration
right and so at some point somebody's
gotta step
up and say i'm breaking the figure eight
i'm gonna stop it
and sexuality and intimacy and
volume that starts with a series of of
environmental offs and ons
not a series of my sex drives more than
yours that's a whole other conversation
that we can have another day
but i want you to start with your
therapist start with your marriage
counselor
i'm proud of you for going man walk in
that door and say hey listen i'm selfish
i'm immature i act like a child
the way i respond to you leaves no
no room for you to even think about
intimacy in here because i've not
created a safe and welcoming place
a place where you belong where your
feelings belong where i can listen to
you where i can just look at you and say
that sucks
i hate that somebody treated you like
that at work today
or man i didn't do the dishes right
again oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm gonna
get it right i walked right past my
shoes
that i left on the front porch i didn't
fill your car up with gas
i'm sorry i'm gonna make that right and
not that little boy rage it's like oh
yeah well i'm taking my bag and going
home
that starts with you matt that starts
with you and i think you've got the
courage to do it
and i'm giving you a hard time because i
see some of that behavior in myself
i see that behavior in millions of men
all across the country
where we were not taught we were not
trained on how to be in relationship we
were taught how to win
we were taught how to compete and we
were taught that being a boy meant being
over
not with and i want you to
and take this time take this snapshot
you've been together a decade
you got decades ahead of you i want you
to take this time with a marriage
counselor and i want you to
learn the skills of connecting learn the
skills of shutting your mouth and being
whiff learn the skills of when you feel
that anger inside
that tells you you're not good you
didn't you failed you suck
that you go nope i am a person of value
she loves me and i'm gonna go make this
right because she's worth it
so matt on honor you man thank you for
the call thanks for reaching out thanks
to everybody who called today
and again i want you to send me your
information
don't forget email me at ask john ramsey
solutions.com
leave your number leave your name leave
all of your information
also don't don't forget to give me a
call again 1-844-693-3291
and several of you have reached out on
social media here's how this works
you're going to call 1-844-693-3291
or you can email it ask john
ramseysolutions.com
kelly daniel who is a rock star rock
star call screener she will call you set
up a time
and we will take the calls back to back
to back on the show and the calls are
live
and we love it you love it thank you so
much for joining us
and as we always do we're going to end
the day
man with us with the lyric of the day
and i'm gonna be honest with you
i wrestled with this because i've got
four or five or six albums that i think
are just incredible
but at the end of the day no album
can touch there's like zeppelin
and the beatles and jay-z and then
there's
a big gap and then there's poison and
there's a bigger gap and on top of that
mountain
sits eric b and rakim eric b
and rakim from their classic album paid
in full
and here's what they want everyone to
know they want everyone to know
eric b and rakeem want everyone to know
they
ain't no joke here's what they say i
ain't no joke i used to let the mic
smoke
and now i slam it when i'm done and make
sure it's broke
what and when i'm gone no one gets out
no one gets on
because i won't let nobody press up and
mess up
the scene i set i like to wander in a
crowd and watch the people wonder
this is the dr john delona's show
you